um
hi my name is markiplier welcome to
sucker for love
uh
this is a dating game
you don't need to breathe on the screen
there this is a dating game
that
like advertises itself as being a
lovecraftian horror
dating game
and that's like a
that's like a cthulhu lady i know that's
not the right term but i'm not brushed
up on my cthulian horror uh but
possibly dating possibly murder possibly
horrible gruesome death
what am i looking at huh
survive chapter whoa
oh
i see
find all three secrets to unlock survive
chapter one okay
survive chapter one
elenata my
relay
scary girlfriend
one
annetta my really scary girlfriend ah
that makes more sense
i see
uh
you know there's a song oh
eldritch god's cosmic horrors things
beyond our understanding to merely gaze
upon their forms to abandon all hope
lixian put a nice like deep rumbly
filter on my voice make it even deeper
deeper
deeper i want elephants to be able to
hear me
because elephants
they communicate with like sub whatever
it doesn't matter the only thing
protecting all of reality from the final
coalescence of insanity and terror is
the fact that the unspeakable gods wait
dreaming
their awakening under aligned stars
heroes
[Applause]
today
the stars are aligned
damn it come on already same day
shipping my ass
i only have half a half hour tops until
the stars move out of position
i better wash my face to calm down
a year ago i saw the face of an eldritch
being in my dreams
it whispered its name to me
lanetta ever since i've been obsessed
with trying to see it again
i'm not the kind of person to get
addicted to stuff or spend recklessly
but i just can't help myself
there's something i have to do once i
see it again
is this
there's something you have to
there's something you have to do
i sent something perverted on the winds
i said oh was that the door thank
goodness
i spent way too much money on getting
this for me to miss my chance
the amount of money i've lost to
scammers claiming to have the real deal
is a little embarrassing but as of today
as of today i'll have a genuine
necronomicon an ancient spellbook
containing the dark rituals needed to
contact the elder gods i love how
seriously this is taking it i love this
finally ow
huh
what the hell is this
why is it pink isn't this supposed to be
like brown and bigger
[Music]
oh that's disgusting it's supposed to be
an ancient book covered in flesh or
something but this looks like it just
came from an office supply store
no please don't tell me
scammed again with how much money i
spent this time i thought there'd be no
chance it'd be fake
great
no way i'm getting my money back either
this gamer is probably long gone by now
damn it i need a new hobby seriously
what a strange scam though you think at
the least go for an authentic look do
they really think no one would notice
that their book of the dead is malabu
oh no
oh no
malibu pink
listen there's a lot of weird stuff
going on my mispronunciations are not
one of them wait is this a symbol on the
front embossed
is this thing made of real leather the
pages look guilt and gold too
and this weight
why'd they make a knockoff out of such
high quality materials
oh my computer
that's probably just delivery
confirmation message
there's a real necronomicon not
clickbait not a scam gone sexual
how'd you guess the title of this video
what the my order was delayed i won't be
delivered until tomorrow then what the
hell is this book supposed to be did it
get delivered to me by accident or
something there's no shipping label in
the box
stranger still this inscription at the
bottom it's relaying the unholy language
of the eldritch gods
also the pages reek of formaldehyde
embalming fluid in other words it stinks
of death
why would something so cute have such an
insidious aura around it
maybe i'll take a look inside
maybe i will
maybe i will where am i huh huh remove
why
take take where they where
whoa
[Music]
what am i equipping what am i equipping
here what am i equipping here right in
the junk area what am i equipping here
and i don't have three hands what is
this equipping to what am i equipping
there what am i equipping here
hmm
this is awfully
suspicious let's see okay all right
let's
hmm ensure all possible light has been
snuffed from the room in your room this
means draw your curtains turn off your
bedside lamp turn off your overhead
lights in the dark light red fire
candles there for your protection the
dark is dangerous find and put on your
ritual necklace when all is complete
chant
lanetta
fart um
magepak
click and drag from the first letter to
the end phrase to chance slowly uh-huh
uh oh
uh uh-huh e interesting aha
what
never leave the lights off that
seems like an important detail
what
her name her name or name her name
boss quentin from concert i'm
dalby
you am
juke or talk
ah
do not cover your ears you will need
them
okay
nothing is just your imagination okay
how
how scared should i be with this
how
how
[Laughter]
i guess i didn't really know what kind
of light-heartedness we would have here
but uh
seems like it's gonna be less all right
close got it turn that off got it
uh turn this off got it in the dark is
dangerous right lead fire why am i still
seeing that
i'm still seeing this
it's not dark yeah it's dark enough i
guess
red
red fire
yeah i ain't good let's keep it red okay
uh
there's no light right what's in here
oh interesting
oh
i don't look so good i don't look good
at all
man what is with what is happening
i expected it
[Music]
okay
ah maybe i could use this to put this
here
no
huh
weird
i could exit why would i exit though
okay whatever this is probably good
enough okay what's next on the list um
ritual necklace you got it bam
original necklace has been placed on the
neck
ritual [ __ ] has not been placed on
the dick
uh
when all is in is complete i mean i feel
like there's still light streaming
through but uh
doesn't say anything about a robe just
says go chant
what okay
what did i get
oh
okay
all right uh no time like the present
let's chant
mortal oh hi
yes that's me how are you would you like
a smooch oh god it actually works she's
here
a beacon of madness is towering over me
an omni but that didn't and chaotic
avatar of world ending calamity even
with a year of preparation for this
moment i'm frozen in fear for what
purpose have you awoken lanetta the star
spawned and brought about the end of
reality
you
know gonna go with horny i can't talk i
can't even breathe
blinding dread choking terror my very
sanity is teetering on the precipice and
looking down
no i finally got this far i finally have
my chance i can't perish now
dark one i ask that you grant my wish
you wish to be the first human to be
destroyed yes
so that you are spared from the
cataclysm i shall wreak upon all life
by destroy if you mean destroy this dick
cut that out no i want a smooch
leave it in because somehow this is
worse
i want to smooch
what
uh
yeah i wanna smooth don't say it again
creep okay how are you looking directly
at me without being driven mad i got my
necklace and my [ __ ] i'm mad with
lunch
send me back
uh-huh uh no
huh but you just got here what about
destroying reality as i know it i'll do
it next time
maybe when the stars realign in a
thousand years or so oh
but i'll be long dead by then
hey i went through all the trouble of
finding this damn book the least you
could do is
well you know
well i don't know
huh what's this
i found it outside my door
always trying to set me up with someone
oh moo
you mean smooch
moo who's that are they the one who left
this funny-looking necronomicon on my
doorstep it's not a necronomicon
sure about that
no
nomicon is bright pink silly that's what
i was saying god she's cute but what's
with the sudden personality change does
she recognize the book
uh well okay if it's not a necronomicon
what is a survival guide
oh for what for dating me
oh you seem more open to it now now
about the smooch what really this thing
it's full of rituals that i like
offerings spells and how to protect your
sanity while performing them oh okay
i struck gold all the money i spent
finally paid off wait what'd you just
say protect my sanity i am a cosmic
entity beyond comprehension so no amount
of contact with me is safe for a human
you got there your mind could snap like
a reed at any moment actually
you got that right
uh gulp oh don't make that face
i can make it worth your while if you
understand what i'm getting at
my face is stuck this way i can't break
it
you let me smooch if you can make it to
the end darling oh
or go insane i'll end reality right then
and there
deal
will you spare the world if i win that
kiss
all right you knew what you were getting
into when you woke me up right darling i
sure did i sure did
looks like my only two options are die
or die without getting a kiss hmm
well they say if you've already eaten
the poison you might as well lick the
plate
i don't know who said that
but i agree
so if the world is going to end either
way
deal excellent
let's begin the date then why don't you
start with the invoke the depths ritual
[Music]
hey you changed my poster what the hell
all right what do we got
invoke the depth uh sir do not perform
this ritual alone snuff all the life in
the room turn on the sink or shower to
make the sound of moving water when all
is complete
do not look out your window from now on
[Music]
hi
what
[Music]
hello
what
hi are you supposed to be there
are you
how am i doing oh
i'm pink
[Music]
put a pink mustache on him
there i am
oh
damn it god damn it what am i pink dawg
all right
so it says sync or shower it does not
say
sink and shower so i'm just go
that's where you're supposed to be
look darling does this look worried
i shouldn't be doing these spells alone
the book says so aren't alone i'm here
okay does that count you know what i
mean these rituals look really bad for
my long-term health long-term health
the world ends when this date does what
does it matter if your mind is
unraveling well nobody is in this world
for the long haul anymore
you got a point there
time to take some risks these rituals
look bad for my short-term health too
well you better finish them quickly then
don't worry
i always finish quickly okay whatever
fine then
snuff all light isn't my light all
snuffed anyway hey turn that off
so i don't need to look out my window
from this point on
ah that was on
okay
i mean it seems good so far
[Music]
is my sink stolen
[Music]
am i supposed to do this
[Music]
that's where i find
[Music]
oh
but
oh snuff all light i see
thank goodness that was forgiving
[Music]
what did i just do you brought the outer
depths to us
didn't you read the spell's name our
connection is stronger now hell yeah the
closer you get to where my true form
lies dreaming the stronger my influence
on you in this world
will i be okay just focus on following
the book perfectly
you're good to start doing these rituals
on your own right oh
no no no no wait why are you leaving i'm
feeling a little icky from the summoning
so i wanted to use your shower do you
mind
oh no not at all go ahead
thanks no peeking
don't peek
okay i won't
oh i won't i won't people sure you won't
come on this is me we're talking about
the most trustworthy person that is in
this room
possibly all right i'll be back
now comes the ultimate test
the most powerful test of will i've ever
endured
i will not be tempted or swayed by that
which i have promised not to do i would
never i would not go back on
[Music]
[Laughter]
there's two branches here okay things
can change
oh whatever
scary my mind is unraveling whatever
okay don't look out your window from now
on
why
[Music]
that's why
what do i look like
i love this
i love it
[Music]
no i would not i wouldn't do that not
again once is enough for me all right
abyssal mist ensure your sinker's shower
is running to make the sound of moving
water then go outside avoid making
contact with that which roams the fog
they'll know if you saw them turn off
your lights before you leave this one
isn't a warning it'll just help lower
your electricity bill chant
[Music]
the shower's on so
i'm not looking at that which roams the
fog
that's nice look at that shadow that's
very nice that's good good trick
jeez it looks like quiet hill out there
with all this fog
darling you didn't i did
love foggy rainy days by the sea i do
too it's like
my favorite weather on the surface world
we have so much in common i didn't know
you have a house on the water
i didn't before but for you anything i
didn't five minutes ago in fact i'm
hundreds of kilometers from the coast
even the wildest of hurricanes would
never flood the area like this what
terrible power is this incapable of
there's something just so romantic about
standing on a balcony during a storm i
know
i know
i'd hate to cut the fun short but can we
go back inside what's wrong darling
getting chilly
well it feels like something's watching
me from out there you can go inside if
you like but it's not like it's any
safer in there after all the next page
in the book has an unspeakable horror on
it
oh
unspeakable horror some kind of monster
is going to jump out of me what i mean
oh
darling what lurks in those shadows
um
something is in that fog
it'll know if i've seen it
i'm not seeing anything in that fog not
a thing
hey how you doing good to see you hey
good to see you hey
good to see you what is this about an
unspeakable horror oh
that
that's it
[Music]
apparently that's it all right
oh god i can't pronounce it what the
hell can't even begin to pronounce this
that's why it's an unspeakable horror
well
i guess you're right
get it as in cannot be spoken
at least not by humans okay
wait you can pronounce this i can i can
pronounce anything oh
what did mouse do
anything anything anything oh yeah and
what's this worcestershire sauce
oh my god
damn you are the real deal hey wait a
minute those tentacles are like extra
tongues right then your weaknesses
tongue twisters
say toy boat ten times faster toy boat
toy boat toy boat toy boat toy boat toy
boat toy boat toy boat toy boat
show off
fine well how about you pronounce it
then
wait a
minute genius
genius hey have you seen my mask and
whatever let's try now
what if it's backwards
[Music]
interesting
[Music]
and i like the bank better
uh
when did i get a rope oh i change it out
i s i know i don't why did i have a robe
in the bathroom
[Music]
robe interesting so to get elders
[Applause]
i shouldn't open that
so i can't pronounce it oh
oh
that oh
this ritual will allow you to order
unspeakable incantations perform the
ritual someplace where gore can be
easily cleaned like a bathroom wear no
robes or ambulance have a ritual knife
on your person
you got it
all right no robes or aiming let's you
say
no need to tell me twice take this i'll
be back
all right let's get that going well it's
not yet okay here we go
eldritch's mouth huh maybe i should have
considered the spell more carefully
before casting it
if there's so much as a single scar i
might actually lose my job
please don't let me have something
freaky on my face it's my livelihood on
the line here okay big breath brace
yourself
ah
i'm done
i'm still cute as hell damn right baby
but i thought i'd get an elder's mouth
or something everything seems pretty
much the same weird
hey lanetta
oh you startled me
oh yeah ah
who the hell was that third voice what
are you talking about that was you look
oh no she takes a hold of my hand
whoa hand holding on the first date
moving fast but that's okay
look at your hands silly
my hand
oh
interesting
get it off quick help me cut it off
hurry cut it off but it's your hand
surely enough it's not a disembodied
mouth stuck to my hand it's very much
embodied mouth indeed
oh this is really my hand what did i do
to my hand darling are you all right
clearly not this is screwed up i mean i
knew i'd be in harm's way but
permanently permanent body disfigurement
this early on but
i'm not stopping before i get that
smooch no matter what i just gotta think
positive
this isn't so bad
i mean there's got to be a silver lining
to this
i could think of a few things
now i have to pick which mouth to use
when i smooch yeah darling
[Music]
someone at the door
this is bad did i get busted the sudden
shock feels like a splash of gold water
that snaps me to my senses damn i must
have done something to give us away was
i shouting too loudly about that knife
did the neighbors call the cops if
someone interrupts my rituals now the
stars will be out of alignment before i
can finish
damn it i even picked the apartment on
the top floor to minimize the number of
people noticing odd sounds or smells
from my room
if it's the police they're gonna insist
on looking around i'm not gonna be able
to smooth talk my way out of a demon in
my room either way i need to prepare
myself now who knows how quickly things
are gonna go south once i answer the
door hello
are you in
i heard you shouting just now
come on let me in
crap it's even worse than the police
there's only one person it could be and
at the worst possible time
what do we do is it even safe to go
outside right now with all the world
bending spells i've been casting darling
the mailman
i'll make him believe and give a just
give him you don't look so good maybe i
should get the door
no no i mean robbie i really don't think
that's a good idea why not
went well
you're a mind playing goddess maybe
it'll be too much for someone who wasn't
expecting it
i guess that's a good point it's a great
point actually if you don't think about
it it's even better point wait here i'll
be right back baby i'll be right back
don't you worry about that thing
[Music]
listen how many times we got to go over
this
i'm not interested in you missy she's an
old money britch girl that suddenly
showed up to the club i work at and
started showering me with gifts
she doesn't quite understand that she's
not supposed to contact me outside
working hours but it's hard to complain
when she basically pays my rent in fact
she's pretty much the only reason i
could afford to buy all this eldritch
paraphernalia
but best of all she's smoking hot
yeah right if i may be so bold i
well i have something special to give
you
may i come in
oh god yes oh hell yes
right this way oh
wait lynette is inside i got so caught
up in the moment i almost forgot uh
actually now's
who now is not a good time have you
looked the fog hmm i think you just give
it to me out here it's
not the kind of present i can give you
out in the open
[Music]
a present that has to be given in
private
oh man what could it be
wait i almost lost sight of the things
again if lanetta and missy meat i'm
toast can i really not help myself with
my life on the line here say something
idiot
i've got
can't get away right now how about we
meet up after work go out after dark
interesting right i forgot her weird
cure why can't we just go inside
i really want to give you your present
now
[Music]
tv
is leonardo coming to the door i can
hear footsteps
who is that
you have company over i have tv it's
called the show's company over you
guessed it
that's just the mail
inside
your apartment
[Music]
yep
i got my
[Music]
[Music]
oh man she's pissed sorry mrs is the
only way i survived this
the mailman
turns out it was one of those uh
door-to-door sales mails man
they could be really pushy you know
[Music]
you'll be swayed by their charms he's
very persuasive
no i got this you just have to be
persistent eventually they give up
did you find leave up
okay
i better smooth things over with her
later before she tries anything crazy
especially now that she knows where i
live better hurry through these rituals
before there's more interruptions
[Music]
all right
i don't think i have
metamorphosis do not attempt this ritual
without performing the calling invokes
the depths
is this the calling this is the point of
no return proceed in total darkness
ensure his image appears in no way and
poster aha
robe necklace mask
ceremonial knife always remember the
second step on the previous page when
all is complete chant so what happens if
you perform this before doing what i'm
assuming the calling is the one that i
got the other thing for
[Music]
what happened
all right so we need uh okay
this
robe
got it
okay always remember the second step on
the previous page which i think is this
one his image appears in no way
[Music]
what's that is that his image
[Applause]
[Music]
damn i look good
damn i look good
god damn i look good okay ah
no i need that
and poster or tapestry
[Music]
what could happen
[Music]
oh
that doesn't sound good
[Music]
hello handsome
did i do it i thought you were cute for
a human before
now you're totally my type
what did i do i'm trying to respond but
no sound is coming out of my mouth
even when i try to shout as loud as i
can i can't even manage to whisper
something is not right what happened to
me
oh
[Music]
god
hang on a second
oh
break up this ritual will suffer your
connection restore your sanity
what are you looking at
nothing
nothing darling lynette
nothing huh yep you were looking at
nothing that's what i said with my mouth
it's right there is that the truth yep
did i scare you darling
[Music]
god
i know what page you were on
and if i see you trying to cast that
spell about nothing
you won't get past the second word
[Music]
okay
i didn't cast this other spell the
this one
what is this one
oh
i got a secret good
great evening
excellent
wonderful this is all going swimmingly
that's for the thing the thing the thing
anyway okay um i don't want to break up
this is going great
this is going wonderfully why would i do
that okay anyway let's draw a symbol no
no wait was that no
that ain't it
is that it that's it okay
collect necessary ingredients from cold
storage
[Music]
sure
cool
that already smells delicious darling i
know baby all it needs is a little
something and it'll be perfect
i'm going to take a short walk outside
while you finish
see you in a few love
love
wow
reach into oblivion oh
[Music]
[Music]
have another life form on your person
what am i what am i uh what am i how do
i feel what am i what's my mood
what's uh what's my uh still bad still
bad still bad still bad still bad
boy howdy still bad okay um
dusty in this room awfully dusty
[Applause]
life form
hmm
[Music]
all right whatever
no crying over spilt milk was an eyeball
in the eyeball
eyeball
all right i got the knife i got the
robot
[Music]
all right let's do it
[Applause]
nothing can go wrong with this
need turtle oh
like ripping off a band-aid that's a lot
of
oh
my god what
oh
you you're not you're you you're okay
you
you
you
you
what is on the bed
my god
what what's happening what do you mean
what's happening what's happening what
do you mean survive
what's happening
what is that about you me he who if you
can read this all reality is doom oh my
god
oh my god
oh my god okay uh if you agree this all
reality is doom once you start the first
world complete all three pages quickly
you will be vulnerable until you finish
do not open any blinds windows or doors
do not turn on any light stuff any
existing lights or you will attract
their attention okay
oh
off okay
uh
okay
swirly do okay
uh
oh my god what in the hell
i think all lights are out okay here we
go
oh my lips don't look too good
oh my god no thank you okay what is the
next one ah she's coming okay cross
oh god
[Music]
oh my god that one okay yeah
okay what next uh okay uh
if she gets in your room it's too late
okay uh uh uh uh i can't really that's
the one
repeat this chance until you believe
you're safe
oh my god
oh my god
[Music]
darling what's wrong your pale is a
sheet
[Music]
can tell by the look on your face
you caught a glimpse of the real world
now that i'm waking up
i guess you aren't as sane as you
thought huh darling
oh sweetie don't worry about reality
it doesn't have anything to do with you
anymore okay though
i should tell you
everything you saw and heard
it's still there oh
what you saw coming through your window
is still coming through
very soon
it'll be impossible to deny its presence
and even escaping reality won't protect
you
who said that i wanted to escape baby if
you like
i could move you to the front of the
line and
and you painlessly myself
as thanks for waking me up
[Music]
near the screams anymore
or feel that chill up your spine where
that tentacle is already touching
baby if it's your tentacle
you can touch me anywhere maybe you'd
prefer to be saved for last
have the whole doomed world all for
yourself for a while
though the things you'd see if you
lingered
baby
the only thing i see is you because you
are my world
there ain't nothing else here that cares
about me me and my admiration forever
being destroyed first or last
which would you prefer
my darling
my name is pronounced d-a-r-l-i-n-g
say it right i'll be last
also what was going on here oh it's gone
i see
i see
nothing is just your imagination of
course not dark communion do not perform
this without performing prepare offering
and reach into the oblivion let the room
be well lit where were no robes have the
offering on your person okay well hey
baby would you like some
whoa
hey dark communion
hey
how well lit this one
[Music]
oh that's good because i can see oh hell
yeah oh
darling
ah that's all i needed to hear
yoink yoink yoink all right baby well
let we do
how well it is that
my darling
shall we commune my love
just perfect
i wish you could make offerings like
this forever maybe i will
maybe i would well my devoted darling
there is only one last spell to perform
i'm already warming it up for you
pledging yourself to me
i was already committed jake
your pledge of devotion will be the last
act of humanity for all of time
yes please
the final words ever spoken by humankind
will come from your fairy mouth and echo
into oblivion
they're only for you
privilege is yours alone
i may be inexperienced with human
emotions but even i know that saying
goodbye to your world can be painful
what did i just say you are my world
take all the time you need to make peace
with the end
i'm going to take a short nap before i
wake up for good
okay did you hit the lights for me
darling
you got it darling
wow what is that you're
wearing thank you my love you're welcome
you're welcome
always here for you
had the ritual
knife on your person chant five times to
fill the
heart well that seems easy enough
but i could do the breakup
but why would i want to no not today not
today
not right now okay
it's ritual knife time
okay here we go
[Music]
love it
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
yep you did wonderfully
right here
i'm afraid it's time for the dream
and our date
to end but before that look on your face
darling i had a wonderful date with you
and that's because of you
so why destroy me and all of reality
why not just stay here with me
that's what you're thinking
right no no not really just here for the
smooch
maybe oh my sweet mortal darling
i'm not doing this out of malice
you've had good dreams before right yeah
sometimes well when you woke up you
destroyed those dream worlds and
everything in them
did you wake up because you hated those
dreams
no
it just couldn't be helped that you'd
wake up eventually all right i love
humans
and i'll miss you sorely
please let your last thoughts be about
that my last thought's gonna be
a tentacley smooch right here i forgot
about my promise to you oh
oh
hell yeah
my
god look at that ass and also look at
the nightmarish horror beyond the window
there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i did it
i did
i did it
all right well okay darling
this isn't because this is this is not
my choices because some of you out there
the weirdos want to save all of humanity
and whatnot where am i our communion
what do i need to do
what am i doing
well lit no robes no necklace you got it
no robes no necklace
[Music]
delicious all right you have a good
night now you have a good night you have
a good night
you got it yeah of course my love well
this is this isn't for me this is my
thing
not my thing
not my thing but whatever some people
you know
whatever
all right let the room be well lit
oh she
[Music]
it doesn't seem to be stopping me before
i get to the second word
lynette
did it work
my face and hands are back to normal
did i really do it
darling
why
well uh it wasn't what it was them it
was them
[Music]
i did what i had to do
sorry darling world's not ending today i
think we should see other people what
why
was i
not good enough
did you have a bad time on our date
listen babe
i can't settle down
i'm a rolling stone
i'm
you're a cosmic horror
i'm
pretty cool is there
is there another woman
look i didn't want to come to this
no none of that it was pretty much just
that you were going to end all reality
then that's it that's the deal breaker
what
but you woke me up in the first place
look i gave you a chance
we both know i got more than i bargained
for
oh darling
you realize i still have control here
right
that's what you always need isn't it you
always need to be in control if you want
to smooch my real form you have no
choice but to do the spells over that's
true
yeah squid is fine too wait what
oh yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
ah
perfect perfect love it hey
hey come on
the good
i
love this
i
really do i love this why is met lanetta
in gray i guess because you can't start
from there
huh but that seems to be all of that for
this one
true endings achieve two of two i like
that ooh
now there is another chapter sucker for
love first date this was amazing i
truly love this so i will be playing the
other chapters i don't know there's
three secrets to get to this one i've
gotten one of them there probably is
another one in here but let's see if we
can find maybe two in here we shall see
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought down the
comments below the other parts of this
will be coming very soon thank you and
as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you